[Music]
so ello everyone first of all it's
really great to be here and I'm stirred
um and it's my first time attending and
speaking at reactance Erdem so today I'm
going to tell a story and it's called
and SVG's tell and it's about a little
girl called SVG and this little girl is
saying some kind of despised by her
family and one day she meets this
awesome boy called react and after that
they start working together and the
SVG's just start being happier but let
me start by introducing Who am I and my
name is Elizabeth I'm actually a senior
UX designer working right now in Dublin
for a company called Upton but I do much
more than a design I also do development
and a little bit of back-end but I'm not
good at back-end so this is my
background I was born in Mozambique in
killing ugly man and when I was 2 years
old
I moved to Lisbon my father is
Portuguese and my mother is from
Mozambique and after that working too
many years in Portugal and in Lisbon I
decided to move to Lisbon a to Dublin
and a lot of people asking me why would
I do that if Lisbon sounds better yeah
the thing is I'm actually thinking and
moving back to Lisbon again so let's see
how it goes so this story is actually
splitted and in different chapters the
first one I'm going to introduce the SVG
and the second chapter
it's when the SVG meets reacts then I'm
going to show you like three simple
projects that you can actually do with
react and SVG the first one is the basic
mode of slideshow then the cassette tape
and finally the react kawaii
so this is the SVG she's a little girl
and she's a little bit sad why because
she's despised by her family and because
she's different from the other images
different from the PNG the gif and JPEG
and why is the SVG different first
this is the definition of the SVG by the
Wikipedia it's basically an xml-based
vector image format for two-dimensional
graphics with support for interactivity
and animation but basically an SVG is
just plain text file where you can see
all of these tags and lines curves and
all of these text will tell all the
image will look like in the browser so
basically the good thing is that you can
actually style the SVG with CSS and the
JavaScript and you can do that with PNG
s and gifts so it's different for first
of all because it's scalable so you can
scale from a small size to a big size
without losing quality or fidelity also
the file size if you scale the file size
will always be the same and compared
with a PNG or a gif or a jpg normally
the SVG is smaller that's the size and
the good thing is because it's
modifiable so with you can style with
CSS and you can change whichever script
and create like awesome animations so
this is my own definition of SVG is an
image with superpowers so you can use an
SVG with as a background image and as an
image but if you use this way you're not
using all the superpowers you're just
basically using the scalable parts and
the file size part but you're missing
the good part there is the modifiable so
to use the muda file so you can style it
and use javascript you have to use it as
an inline SVG I never tried with the
object so I can tell much but I
recommend the inline SVG so this is the
part of the story when the little SVG
when she meets the react and as you can
see she's actually sad she said because
she doesn't know that she has all the
superpowers and she thinks that she's
liked her family
but she thinks she's worse but we act is
this guy it is awesome boy always happy
and she tells you know what little SVG
you have all these superpowers and I can
show you how to use their superpowers
so in the react world we can actually
use the super powers of the SVG in two
different ways
the first one is to import the SVG as a
react component and the second one is to
transform the SVG into gsx so in the
first one
imported react component is actually
very straightforward as you can see and
image you just if you use something like
create react app or if you used some
kind of web pack loader you just need to
import react components as in this case
logo and then you just have the
component right there but you can
actually see all the SVG tags but if you
expect in the browser they will be there
so the good thing of this you don't need
to convert into GSX
you won't have like HTTP requests
because the code is in line it's perfect
for simple animations and to style with
CSS and also is very good if you want to
after that update to design so imagine
that you want to change something that
in the design you just need to update
the SVG file so this is like an example
of what you can do basically you can
have like the file and then in this case
I'm using pop motion as you can see you
have to target in this case I'm wearing
the ID selecting the ID and then you
have to perform the animation by
performing like this Dom animations and
I think it's a little bit difficult to
do that so I actually prefer this way
for creating animations and to use the
SVG's with react and you can first of
all you have to transform into GSX
and that's really easy you have a lot of
websites where you can just put there
the cold and it automatically changed
from the real SVG to JSX
the good thing is actually you won't
have HTTP requests it's very good if you
want to do like code splitting so you
need you don't need to have one big file
you can split the SVG and multiple files
and this is also a very good thing you
can use make use of the props States and
all the event handlers but then a pet
thing is actually really complex if you
want to update the design so imagine
that you have like illustration and days
after the designer says oh we want to
update these parts of the design because
you already split the design in
different parts you have to find that
part and replace and probably it's
already JSX and make these their
different props so it makes really hard
if you want to update the design but the
question is why should you transform an
SVG into components
why would do that so I found two use
cases the first one is if you want when
you made the SVG and the second one is
if you want to make it customizable so
this is a very basic example of what you
can do with SVG isn't react it's a very
simple model slideshow and in this
example I'm using react and reacts pose
so this is what I wanted to achieve it's
very simple so I have like a border left
and this purple border right and my idea
was if I click in the arrows I wanted to
move the borders to the right and to the
left so the idea was that so first thing
that I did was I start by splitting and
creating this structure so this is the
model and inside the model I will have
like different elements the border left
or the right and the styles is basically
I'm using stylus components for that
and then I have this function and all
animation there is receiving like one
parameter called direction direction and
we that what I do is after when you're
going to click one of the arrows I'm
going to set the state of the animal and
you might world it to true and after
some milliseconds is going to false and
I'm saving in the state direction that
is going to be left or right basically
this is like another function you make
left where I'm calling the end of
animation and then I'm just changing the
slide very simple and then this is
actually the JSX of the model so inside
I have like this component for the left
and for the right
they are basically SVG's and then I have
the own click in the arrows and where I
perform the animation left and right and
I'm just passing all these props to the
border left components so basically I'm
saying what is the direction the
duration and if the animate border is
true or false so this is the SVG as you
can see it's very simple this is the
path the phoenicians you will see after
and I'm using react pose to perform the
animation so this is ReactOS so i have
initial pose that is like a wave reset
and then when i click to the right or to
the left i passing that state left or
right so it's going to perform or the
left animation or the right animation
and what the animation is basically
doing is i'm going from the wave reset
to the wave contracted if it's the left
and if it's the right animation I'm
going from the wave reset to the wave
expanded and this is basically the path
definitions I just exported from sketch
I don't know how to do these like I
don't know all these numbers so what I
do
sigh on.i you sketch and I created like
the images and then I exported the wife
contracted the wave reset and the wave
expanded and this is like the final
result I'm using code sandbox for that
so if I click right this is what
happened and if I click left so as you
can see is very simple and this I could
have like that slide show up to be like
a very basic but we just a little bit of
SVG and animation it ended up being much
more awesome and now there's vidi as you
can see is much more up here you start
to leaving oh maybe I have superpowers
thank you reacts for that for showing me
that and this is another project that I
created like 2016 at this time I was
living in Lisbon I think no no I was not
living in Lisbon but when I was living
in Lisbon first I went to do a iOS
course and I had to do a final project
and my final project that is because I
really like hip-hop I used to be like a
hip-hop artist but it didn't go well so
I ended up following a different part in
my life so but I always liked hip-hop
and freestyle so to do my final project
I said yeah I'm going to do like this
iOS ax a cassette tape where I can press
play and I will listen to you pop loop
and then I can record my freestyle on
top of it it seems like a good idea but
once I start trying to do like with Auto
layout and Xcode it became like a
nightmare and I couldn't achieve a
properly ID'd the functionality was
there but layout was awful so ears after
I found this design of my laptop and I
said yeah probably now
was already living in Dublin and I said
probably now I should try to do it again
and I start researching and I found out
that now the two browsers actually
support recording your voice in the
browser so I said okay I can try to do
it again and this time with technologies
that I know so let me try to do which
have a script so I did the first version
just with jQuery and the second version
then we'd react so this is what I did
i ported from sketch this image and as
you can see i have all the elements
there to play in the past because then
i'm going going to manipulate with with
react and so first thing what with as we
go to create a to optimize and then this
is actually the structure so all the
recorder things go here and then i have
all of these small elements inside the
cassette folder and then this is like
basic example when you convert the SVG
to JSX
as you can see it's very similar with
the real SVG but only different is like
here like instead of having font -
family we have this camelcase
font family and the good thing is we can
actually pass props and state and all of
this thing this is an example in the
cassette tape where i have the play in
the record function so basically here
I'm just playing with the state's I'm
checking if it's the cassette tape
playing and the play list where is the
current track if it's recording or not
and then this is what it looked like to
pass props to the children's components
so I have this cassette there is
basically the rapper and then the center
is where the wheels leave so - dude like
two wheels animation I need is playing
state and is recording and then I have
all these buttons and for the buttons
I'm passing like
the play and these record functions and
the state if it's playing if it's
recording and then this is an example of
the center GSX
and in here I'm just to perform the
animation I'm just checking if I'm
playing
if the cassette is playing or is
recording and if it's playing I start
the wheel animation if it's not playing
I stopped the wheel animation this is
where the buttons live I'm just giving
the example of the play pause button and
I have elected zone click and learn with
the play function and now let's see what
did I choose and I can actually record
my voice
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what a pyro come to him and that
[Applause]
okay thank you thank you yeah so as you
can see now the little SVG is much more
heavier now he knows what I can even
like do hip-hop so it's like wow so the
next project is actually called react
kawaii and this is like an example the
two example before was basically an
example why you can like grab an SVG and
animated with this example is more like
you can create like components that you
can actually customize so I think maybe
probably two years ago I created like
this library I was just I'm just a to a
person that is too lazy and because I
always get these jobs that I'm actually
doing design and at the same time I'm
doing front-end and then I end up not
having time for anything so every time I
try to do Alice tration for a project I
always try to do and a lazy way there is
really something simple reusable and
that can I actually cover different
scenarios so one day I had this idea I
was thinking what if I could have like
an illustration like bootstrap alert
components where I could just stay and
define the states like if it's accessing
for warning so I thought maybe I can
create animation with this and that's
when I started researching and I found I
really knew about touka wise but just
doing the research I said yeah probably
the Kawai is a good way of doing like
this type of illustration that covers
different scenarios so I thought okay
it's perfect to transform into a
component because I actually can just
have like put of a cute face on top of
anything and then it's a kawaii so I can
have like a planet with a quick cute
face on it a browser or an ice-cream and
so I thought okay this is perfect to
create like customizable illustrations
so first thing that I did
like an SVG I did it one sketch and I
exported and then I converted to JSX
and then I start defining the face
components so I created like different
states sad shocked happy all of these
states and then I exported from sketch
and with as we go I quit I try to
optimize a little if you could see I
have the paths here it was it was
actually sorry Vieira helping me in
these parts so we moved all the pets
definitions to a different file so the
the face component can seem much more
smaller and as you can see this is just
different if statements if the mood is
blissful or lovestruck
lovestruck or excited I'm actually
putting one parts of the SVG if it said
it's another part of the SVG so it's
just that and then I have the kawaii
component and the Kawai component is
basically the body and decide the body
is where the face lives and the
components in this case is the planet
component it receives different props
the size the color the mood and if you
can see I have here to this properties
weed and height and I'm just basically
replacing with the size prop so then if
the user says the size is 300 pixel it's
going to replace here and if it says the
mood it said it's passed to the children
component and then in the end you can
have something like this but you just
say okay that I want is planet with this
color and this size and this mood and
this is actually our you can call the
component and you can do this for your
own illustrations
and then I decided to move this library
to NPM and you can install this is just
NPM install and that's it and now let's
see it to parse it's just because I like
to show off the page I'm actually using
the style guide list it's a little great
to create these things and so this is
basically the things that you can do you
have different modes and you can pick
the mood that you want the color the
size this is actually my favorite one
the backpack is the last acquisition
let's say and all the backpack is sad
because my talk is almost at the end oh
I also like the cat to be sad as well
it's a sad cat so this is basically the
library as you can see now the SVG and
reacts they are best friends forever
because they finally realized the SVG
finally realized that she can do so many
things and she can create animations
like the model or the cassette tape she
can have all of these customizable
components like to be at Kauai and you
can do this too let's just write to
create more components and things with
SVG is that you can actually interact
and instead of having like a boring
model we can have like a cool model so
let's do that so last year this project
wonder fun side project of the year here
in the reactant tsardom open source
Awards and it's really great because
last year I couldn't attend to pick the
prize and Here I am today and I'm really
happy and I really want to say thank you
for react Amsterdam
for the invitation and that's it what
makes the web fun again and that's the
end of my talk and I hope you like it
just follow me
you